hello everybody and welcome back to the
amnesia custom story abduction alright
we're in some sewer level here I'm sure
there's a water monster to be had oh oh
no no water monster huh he knew what was
good for him I mean best not to fight me
all right lots of boxes hopeful epic
leap we got here labora toy
Dexter's Laboratory was a good show if
any of you remember that alright why do
we got oh is dark again big surprise oh
no oil damn it I'm all out of oil ah is
bad Oh pile of dead bodies what else is
new give me some uh huh Oh
oh god I couldn't tell what that was huh
oh hello dude um you all right there
buddy you don't look so good
just be on my merry way huh blue I
didn't know what that was sort of popped
out at me well it's a whole new
experience playing without any oil it's
even more immersive and whatnot Oh oil
thank goodness gravy and la donna numb
gimme gimme all right it's not much but
it's something more boxes gonna be very
conservative nope
oh man what do we got
nothing nothing nothing absolutely
nothing that was a waste of time huh
and once again I've got way too many
tinderboxes huh what was that what was
that I don't know I don't know what was
that what what what what what hey ho
let's go away from here all right
whatever I'm I'm braver than this and no
yeah no one just gonna close the door
behind me like think all right this
doesn't look so bad oh we got here oh
cages barrels Oh squishy doodad oh do I
have anything to squish nope nothing
Oh al every Headey doodad um a Bunsen
burner II thing oh I'm at a key area
finally I'm a useful chemical storage
now where is chemical storage
oh yes follow the trail of blood that
seems ah ah more squish sounds like
knife going in body oh no no no no no no
no all right yeah it's not so bad huh
worried about nothing that arm
what arms my arm oh those arms ah
oh yeah thing that doesn't look good in
the boxes oh oh oh
jiggly jiggly oh oh it wants me to put
the arm in the UM
the the squeezy Burnie thing I know I
know
yeah yeah this is normal
any sane person would do this don't mind
me just carrying my arm to the
laboratory why what are you doing don't
look at me like that I do do I squish it
maybe oh yeah squish it oh wait you
gotta get my glass jar cuz I'm so smart
no use it yo you son of a there we go
there's a little piggy go don't don't
mess with me
good you son of a gun go dragging my
mouth like across my mouth bad there we
go finally good gravy
now do I burn it up hello maybe oh hello
what do I burn I had instructions about
this didn't I uh-huh no not that how the
blood you defined mercury and bromine
okay I need to use this chemical storage
thing to get those ingredients all right
bring it on
Oh who's out there nobody that's what I
thought okay I'm guessing there was
nothing else in here all right sewers
back to the sewers
I'm sure the chemical storage is on the
other side here up no water monster no
they don't dare mess with me ah you need
to make a portal potion what what is a
portal potion this makes no sense
whatever oh good thing I got it right
here oh yeah I'm do best
oh look at me I'm so great Oh lag lag
for lack okay no luck
my computer is too good for lag oh doors
doors close behind me cuz I want death
to sneak up on me
more oil yeah and a chair like I needed
huh Oh No
no spiders Fu the mind is crawling with
him blah blah blah mine anyway little
bastards a resilient spires actually
died when he crushed him Wow
what do you know alright we're just some
crazy guy who cares a DFSA
ten bucks and a key Oh another tinderbox
why don't mind if I do try to be very
sparing with my lantern use of damnit
dark hallway let me see what's down here
these look like chemicals anything I can
use anything glowy what are you I can't
go away in the box laudanum tinderbox
all right I think that was it I don't
see anything else
Oh God
this has to be blocked all right no more
oil down the dark hallway Oh bring it oh
don't do this don't do this to me
though no no no laughs you get out of
here Oh No
stop it stop it I hate you I hate you
give me your head your head oh no okay
oh [ __ ] you I'll take you all on I'll
take you down with me
Oh crawl crawl on my belly
trolley crawl crawl oh okay okay where
am i what am i doing oh well I'm okay
I'm okay I'll need a sanity potion
because I'm okay
oh man I was well
oh man I wasted a lot of way on that
little adventure don't do this to me
don't
don't okay I got bromine I need mercury
[Music]
okay I'm okay look at me I'm so okay not
great but I'm okay
Oh more chemicals tinderbox nothing use
the tinderbox on laudanum
so yeah here primary off' room area but
the heck is primary off' best leave it
alone whatever Oh
messing up your [ __ ] Oh what do you
think of me now go scare me uh-huh screw
your bottles
I don't worry I didn't break any of them
a giant pansy apparently wait wait what
this doesn't make any sense what's going
on here I'm about to run out of oil damn
it mine interests hang on wait I'm
exploring an unknown here because
there's a door open here and I didn't oh
it's not a door nevermind I'm stupid
okay it's bright oh oil thank goodness
gravy need oil needs so much oil oh man
what's this
hello touch you know I cannot okay Oh
box ain't nothing Oh get out of here I
must have been the door that was blocked
all right
oh let's see what's going on over here
in the mine entrance actually I'm gonna
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you next time
bye bye